hello reject nation it's Greg Alva here
and I'm John so we watch black lightning
the other day and we really enjoyed it
and the reviews are in and people are
loving it right now
but as we know critics and audiences can
often disagree and that's what we love
using the Stardust yeah we're on the
start of SAP oh and thank you guys for
following us we just passed 4,000
followers I think we have like about a
hundred twenty posts on there so far
right now down posso down low up home
soon so we love using it and we have a
compilation of the combination of people
that follow us and no accommodation of
people that we follow that we haven't
seen any of the reactions for yet
sometimes John and I would just like to
binge-watch because they have this
button where you could hit a certain you
can hit the movie sometimes and they
just like have people saying yeah so we
thought it would be fun to do that for
Black Lightning I know John to deference
idiots yes
let's check out what these people go to
sign I'll do it let's rock'n'roll and
you just see how good he is and you can
tell that he's been dying with
anticipation and just perfecting the
suit for the last seven years and
constantly improving that it's just so
excited it's funny I think she has a two
parts the first one is when he gets
supercharged
Montella you figure out
obviously you'll figure out how it works
but the scene in which that will make
more sense and then the other scene is
right before he is destroying the car in
that whole scene well Zoomer make some
good points there that's the only one
we're gonna watch we'll stop and talk a
little bit about what there's a I liked
what she said about that because I
remember we did the reaction for it
which is on our patreon when I first
thought was Alfred Alfred was also the
guy from daredevil who makes the suits a
combination of that I think that Alfred
that we get now especially on the DC
movies is very much like this in terms
of he designs the equipment in yeah with
all these things sophisticates yeah it's
like an Alfred and it Gordon combined
yeah yeah this is my first exposure to
this basically other than a trailer and
there was like a magic about their
relationship to I was like dude he's
been waiting to do yeah he's gung-ho and
yeah it is exciting it's kind of like if
Alfred really wanted Bruce Wayne to not
give up on being Batman yeah there was
the antithesis to the Dark Knight Rises
hey don't take care of your body and
actually for me I've been psyched for
this show since it was originally
announced it was really really good
great beginning his backstory
I'm really glad as the daughters are in
here and the daughters so wasn't the
friend of Victoria Isabella the creator
of this character wait what did he mean
by the ended oh oh so we can't trust Eve
C 50s you know because he's being biased
you know we follow him I was
surprisingly given four stars because it
just seems like you know I really like
kind of guy who like four-stars ism is
good like like five stars would have to
be something I would imagine say truly
translate to you know a Steve what's
your rubric man break it down for
Akasaka son what's up man I won't lie
black lightning it was pretty oh like
for a pilot for pilot it was pretty cool
um there were some parts that were a
little cringy and some of the dialogue
was a little hand fan a little force but
overall the concept in the setup in the
world our building I think works really
well I would love to see him team up
with the rest of the hair over so I
definitely recommend checking it out
yeah okay well he actually made some
good points I don't know if anything
made me cringe I think you said it best
in the review portion of our video
that's on YouTube ah that obviously
there's some pretty expositional
dialogue here and there but it's always
well justified for why they're bringing
it up so sorry Gabby like I've known you
since you were 12 years old you're like
a son to me remember what I said to you
in pretty much every scene with one of
the characters but it's a pilot and you
got to get to all the information out of
the way you're doing a lot of world
setup and honestly I know the shows that
come from the DC TV and I think that
that's better hand a lot more successful
than others but I always thought that
the expose they always tried to deliver
it in a creative way they never got just
dropped you an information load it never
lost its emotional context just to like
to spit out some information what he's
saying about the arrowverse I think that
would be cool I really hope that they
don't do that I don't even want to say
the first season I'm hoping that like
after the second season is when he could
maybe start doing that I would really
like really establish your own thing
right now because I like the arrowverse
a lot I love flash and arrow and I like
the sprinkles of like crossing them over
through episodes every once in a while
like a character here a character there
a reference here a reference there but
what made this so special was that none
of that felt you're not
yeah your honor do you don't have to
think about that database while you're
processing yeah and it gets to be its
own thing the way Supergirl does it is
she's from another earth so you kind of
do something like that if you wanted to
I don't see whether we need to call them
blighter you come in handy
dude black lightning y'all that was
super intense accessibility enemy and
just like the overall feel of the show
is it's so much more mature than what
we're watching you know the other hard
and fun but this one is very yeah yeah
bringing those real life issues to race
yeah and everything just you know yeah
the guy holding cameras the hype man
yeah and he also knows when to turn the
mic he brought up a good point about how
it's having a more mature manner then
the other shows I wouldn't say that
arrow is 100% light hearted from the for
DC TV shows I think arrows definitely
the darkest one of them all is the most
brooding one of them all and it's kind
of the most self serious one words like
kind of cheesy dramatic sometimes it's
like awesome dramatic and in their times
you're taking yourself way too seriously
what was cool about this was all the
serious stuff hit I really feel like
there were one step away from being a
damn good cable show because some of the
dialogue and violence you're like I know
they're held back by censorship for
being on the CW because this is a game
world or and I can imagine if they were
on a cable channel it probably would've
been like similar dialogue just a little
bit more raw and it's vulgarity or swear
words or whatever but it still felt like
a primetime show yeah absolutely
chainsaw reacts we know this guy hey
what's up just finished watching the
series premiere for Black Lightning I
really enjoyed it I really did the more
the episode went on the more I was
really digging it I like the fact that
they really gave a lot of detail of his
past because he's been retired for nine
years from being black lightning and
then seeing him kind of fight with
coming back
way because he made a really good point
in the episode I have to mention he said
I've saved more lives as a principal at
this high school than I ever did it's
black lightning which is debatable but I
really enjoyed this episode can't wait
for next week I'm so glad he brought
that up because that was a point that I
totally forgot to mention in the review
of one things that we comment on was how
this whole episode was a debate episode
of philosophy episode should or
shouldn't he of course he's going to but
it's like you know having that question
when you think I'd like to save the cat
structure for films how it goes is like
about 12 minutes into a movie there's a
catalyst moment than a debate of whether
or not they should go on this adventure
this whole episode just like the star
catalyst to do especially nowadays like
now in the sort of postman our hero
world or I don't know what to call it
but you know there's lots of context
around we're very aware and so now that
we have more superheroes than ever it's
like really important arguably to start
to your show with like should he or
should he not or not you know oh yeah
why why are we having this that's what
makes it gripping because the show
starts off with him telling his daughter
something about violence against
violence just creates more violence it
doesn't actually make anything better is
it okay to commit violence when is it
appropriate when is it right cuz it's
like you can save the world by being a
principal in its own aspect or sometimes
you could save people though by actually
getting your hands if he dirty and
hurting some people maybe sometimes
having to kill someone like Zod is also
about figuring out which world you're in
because throughout the episode you're
seeing totally different places you're
at the school you're out just in Jeff's
life when they get pulled over and then
you're in Lala's territory you're seeing
a lot of different again philosophies
clash of yes well that's what I really
like about that line because I'm hoping
[ __ ] hits the fan in terms of his
personal life and everything just starts
I want that's the tension that I feel I
really set up well is a hero as a
principal a hero this and then knowing
that both can be okay cuz I don't want
it to be it's a smooth sail for him as
black lightning from here on out I want
it to be like there are terrible things
happening because he's black lightning
and there's also good things kind of
like how daredevil does that like
there's good
good being daredevil but there's a lot
of bad things that come with being
daredevil - I'm glad that chainsaw
pointed that out - because that that is
a compelling argument like has he saved
more lives as a principal or his black
debate - though and the fact that they
brought it up in both directions when
they make the argument for a why it's
necessary that he do the black lightning
stuff I'm like well yeah seems like some
of these places are beyond like look
John I know some people at CW I'm gonna
spoil something for all you guys the
next episode you find out every kid who
graduated when he was principal is not
part of the 100 game so he's harmed and
helped grow a gang how could you
Matthew V Haynes from this thumbnail
it's him with two lovely black letters
all right mm-hmm
ladies you just finished watching by
lightning or three of us man what do you
got of action and drama just craziness
horrible one it was so surreal so funny
scary relatable all the emotions on the
one has a cool touching moments - which
I really like yeah you guys go watch the
episode I think the show's worth day and
I think this one had a great run this
season you know I like what you said
about in this action drama and it's
funny it's scary it's scary and there
are times but like when lawless being
abusive to his kid that's intense when
Tobias shoots
lalla with the harpoon that's intense
and kind of scary you know or when
they're in his office that first time
and they're about to take her down the
seahorse Motel yeah it shoots those
things in in in a naturalistic way where
you're like this would be a horrifying
situation to be there is pretty good
amount of action in it and the dramas
really well handled and there are times
where we laugh - because it was actually
funny at times like it's a really well
balanced emotional chef and it kind of
effortlessly at least to me managed to
lighten up appropriately and get serious
appropriately they have their Jack White
you know like Strymon about to lay down
some justice music but then they also
have some really gripping tense real
yes and the actions great too because
like the debate is about the action so
like when it gets there and when it
doesn't it's like meaningful you know
the thing when he fights is he fights
violently it's like he's repressed
having to fight so when he starts
fighting he's like that's where the
emotional state comes into the way he
moves well right there with you I praise
yes we were pretty tired we were you
know we rather shoot this tonight or
rather shoot this is immortal oh shoot
what word spry yeah it's fun to watch
something on the day it premieres it's a
good late night show for sure
and John's in love with you we
definitely see eye to eye on black jazzy
J 100 series program black landing and
exceed my expectations you know I was
really looking forward with you know I'd
seen all the trailers and stuff but
exceed my expectations this was really
good I love how we've seen you know
we're tired but like actually get back
in school cuz his daughters right now
like involved it in the mix and the
songs like defending his family now his
daughter and I use of developing powers
which is like really good it's really
gonna be nice to see and I just like
it's nice to see a black like male lead
in the show yeah the biggest touch that
I just don't notice that because it
seems like so normal I know it's not
normal to see like a black led superhero
like best were made Luke HS a video
that's what makes Black Panther the
movie a big deal this is making this a
big deal for the DC world and especially
what they mean in the comic book origin
in the comic book world that is huge I
just have no like oh [ __ ] I don't have
it's weird I was thinking about this
back when I started watching it Lena I
think was just the debate about there
aren't a lot of black LED or or
predominantly black mainstream huge
budget shows and stuff and when you see
it half your brain or for me half my
brain is aware because half of me is
like cool
see see yeah it works just the same
that's my point it's like it just feels
like it just works for me so I don't
ever I'm never like pulled out going
black people it is cool the show doesn't
even do anything that really draws
attention to itself like that it deals
with race it does especially with the
way the police are there's a lot of
racism that takes place there it's just
the world that they're in and I fight
stulen hooah the state takes place but
when I think about the show in terms of
that retrospect I'm like that actually
is pretty cool because I don't know the
proper words for this I'm just gonna
speak in it truthfully
it kind of has like that black flare
about it like and the way the style is
the soul of the show of the people there
in a positive way you know and I love
feeling that culture Nick yeah it feels
like a black show I guess that's the
thing yeah right because I don't like it
has its own distinct palette yeah it's
got its own unique soundtrack it feels
authentic to me anyway I mean I am NOT
black so in so many ways I guess I
couldn't tell you that or not but it
feels authentic to me you know yeah
there's a lot of universal stuff in
there just the same yeah well a lot of
the black guys can get away with saying
a lot of the cooler dialog to Luke Cage
has a lot of cool lines in his show just
the way how he talks with like the other
gangsters and stuff there's like a
certain style to the dialogue yeah she
also pointed out that it really is like
a strong family show as well yeah that
element distinctly between both him and
his ex-wife plus the complicating
situation with his daughters and none of
that ever feels forced
yeah it all feels kind of appropriate
we balance there I'm wondering too cuz
his daughter was the one who's like you
know I haven't take a stand I had to
fight and then he's always like he's
Falls School protocol yeah I shouldn't
be fighting what are you thinking what
are you doing stuff like that so there's
gonna be a point where he discovers she
has powers as I don't know if the
daughters know that he's black lightning
I can't tell obviously the ex-wife knows
it but I think in the comics the whole
family knows but I don't know if in the
show right now the daughters know either
wit there's gonna be a conversation to
be had about like you shouldn't be doing
this you're my daughter you should be in
school and she's like you're black white
his decision whether or not to come back
is like intrinsically tied to his
relationship with his family and there's
also a family that is clearly a very
important a very precious very
personally driven I love it and I can
tell that there's gonna be a lot more to
the family dynamic as things go forward
and one thing I want to give it credit
to you is the relationship between him
and his ex-wife like that's a more
compelling romance to root for for did
we get together then a lot of the other
shows it feels like a more real thing I
get you he's changed his whole life
around just to try to get her back you
know ya know we love this show I give it
five out of five stars John not really
Doug if we're gonna continue doing
reactions for it but like we said guys
this is one of our ways of featuring
your star risk reactions if you follow
us tag us in one of the ways you can get
feature in a real rejects video and
thank you to all who are featured in
this video because it allowed us to
springboard off a lot of thoughts that
we didn't get express in the actual
reaction that we did because that was
just a reaction oh yeah think about it
it was cool to watch this and it's cool
to hear other people's thoughts you know
because everybody catches that different
alright guys well thank you you can
download the Stardust app and follow us
first link in the description box people
and you can subscribe to the real
rejects why don't you click that
notification bell to get notified every
time one of our videos is up because
subscribe buttons don't work and you can
check out our patreon where we got
full-length TV show reactions and music
video reactions on there because those
always get blocked on YouTube
[Music]